[Music]
action i want to talk about the last
topic
no anthony we will be moving on and i
actually want to ask you
anthony lee no okay so this next topic
is about
uh dealing with celebrities and seeing
how they are like in real life
like how oh like you meet your favorite
art and you're just like you [ __ ] i wish
i'd never met you you [ __ ] actor
meet your hero oh my god yeah so there's
this tick tock
uh that was pretty popular and there's
this chick where she talks about how she
was a hostess
at a fancy manhattan restaurant and
she's
and she was raiding celebrities based on
her experience with them so let's watch
oh i think i'll watch this oh that's
tough though here we go it is tough
that's true oh no not this one
it was another lady yeah who's she she's
a horse
in manhattan so first off we have the
hadith sisters
these two are literally so nice i could
not say enough things about them
wow they're super polite and friendly
with staff which unfortunately is rare
for celebrities
10 out of 10. next up we have mad con
star cameron dallas
i kind of had
[Music]
this is going to be controversial i've
met her a handful of times and every
time she was not nice that's bieber's
mom
[Laughter]
next up we have kylie she was fine but
she took twenty dollars on a 500
damn twenty dollars on a five hundred
dollar bill
percent tip wow usually in america
yeah so you can continue the
conversation you're laughing
well you're you know what's crazy though
i feel like
celebs and people that are known
we're more forced to tip bigger
just because of image and everything
else
um because people talk they'll be like
damn [ __ ] true i think there's like a
subconscious like when we go out to eat
like we we try to tip
more than we used to before like our
life
in youtube i make a deliberate attempt
to be
just average so 15 15 15 to 20
yeah well 20 is now the new average
isn't it i wouldn't say it's a new
average i think the new average is 25.
you know what you go on those people
from postmates grubhub doordash
the when it pops up how much you want to
tip the button's always on 25
and i'm like oh yeah oh especially now
is this white people tip
first of all that's just rigged though
because like with delivery services in
general
delivery charges also go towards like
the person who's working yeah and then
they're obviously as tenants also
like contractors writing off certain
things as well and then you know because
i used to deliver for a
bj's a pizza when i was like in college
i love beach and it's like when people
give you a tip
that tip money is on top of your
delivery service charge
on top of your hourly wage i'm not
saying that i'm getting paid the most
i'm just saying they're technically
already getting something for the
delivery conceptually speaking oh
maybe there's postmates people out there
there why does it put on 25 then
that's what i'm saying really i really
tip postmates depending on how i
received my pokemon paid 70
for pancakes because i live in like a
like an l.a apartment and i and i
apologize it's not as easy as like a
cul-de-sac house right
going up to a door that hasn't had just
like this is the place sometimes with
the apartment
you gotta like go up to the call box
yeah you gotta get out your car in an la
place you gotta go to the call back
no just to find parking periods yeah you
know i get it it's a penny ass
but it's the point of the job
you know what i don't know we signed it
for you yeah that's like a ups worker
going
apartment yeah you know i mean it's like
well you signed up for this so so if
like a postings person makes me walk out
of my apartment go to the street
that tip's gonna be very different from
if they're hitting me up at the call box
yeah
yeah um do you feel the same when it
comes to like
wait like tipping a waitress absolutely
i think good service deserves a good tip
i think bad service doesn't deserve a
tip that's why it's called the tip
right i think i'm at the point now where
i i feel like i'm pretty fortunate i
feel
financially stable so bad service i
still get 15
but if they do a really good job that'll
tip way more to me it's like
if you're just doing your job it's 15
but if you do something that's a little
bit
more or like okay that was quick and a
smiley face on the receipt
because i think i'm way more harsh
because i used to wait tables
same because if i see somebody sitting
there
and it is an empty ass restaurant
they're not doing jack [ __ ] and my
drink is taking forever to get to me and
they're just [ __ ] on the phone or
whatever
[ __ ] that dude like why should i tip
them and then they get mad
and they get mad when i don't tip them
oh sh so you do leave zero tip
depending on the service because i'm
thinking about it as like when i was a
server
i would have [ __ ] hate to work with
this person because i
like i don't know the restaurant
environment it's supposed to be like a
team right where like
you know sometimes people don't know
that you're not the the server to a
table so they'll just
look at any waiter and be like hey can
you refill my water
it's not my table but i don't tell
people like that's not my table i'll
tell your [ __ ] server
grab the water i'll be like here you go
and then like i don't go up to the
server be like hey man
can you split the tip with me because i
helped you out like it's like
it doesn't work like that you just
[ __ ] do the work for that table
and then they'll do the work for you and
then you kind of scratch each other's
backs
but there are selfish [ __ ] servers
out there that are just
only care about their table they're just
sit there all day the restaurant's busy
and they're like i'm going to break
and it's like [ __ ] you dude so because i
understand that
resentment that i carried on for over a
decade
when i'm at a restaurant i'm like a boss
i'm just like
[ __ ] you man i don't know but you still
deserve 15
because i'm doing good right now during
these times during these times because i
know it's tough
and since we have barbara which is like
a mom and pop shop too
i just understand how hard it is across
the board i just tip 5 to 10
more so like the 70 pancakes it was
probably like
maybe like 40 bucks but then or 50 bucks
i just tip 20 bucks i just know it's
tough all around
i say i'm hard but i'm actually
dependent on how i feel if i'm having a
good day dude you got 30
you didn't do [ __ ] but i'm feeling like
charitable today
that's like people tip more during
christmas time really
and i'm assuming during this pandemic if
you can
afford it people are you want to go to
the grocery store [ __ ] do you want to
help out i always help out three books
it was one three five but three's in the
middle so
what if you don't have cash literally
when you swipe your card
like i don't know sometimes it's like
just because you want to help you want
to help people that are in need during
these times i'm like sure
there's just three balls oh the way you
do it though it makes you feel like you
have to
do you wanna you wanna save the hungry
children yeah you're like you're like
don't judge me but no i hate when the
cashier asks me because i'm like can can
i just feel the judgment from the
machine like why does that have to be
from a person
that's how they get you you know what i
mean yeah that's why i'm like every
single time
absolutely one dollar
[Laughter]
you feel like really good like everybody
wins
service based off of the establishment
you're at
because yeah for me i'm much more
forgiving when it's like mom or pop
or or just different culture or like i'm
less forgiving at mom or pop
really i feel like mom and pop because
like real good mom and pop spots
it's really personal it's not very
corporate i mean like there's a hole in
the wall
mom and pop where i know what you're
saying the mom and pop is arguing while
they're giving you food and [ __ ]
and you're just like home but for
at that point though i don't even the
the standard of my tipping and the
restaurant culture it goes out the roof
like i mean i not it just goes out the
door because i'm thinking about
i'm eating at grandma's house right now
and they're she's they're fighting
that's how i am like if i'm at like a
baller ass place yeah
and between every 10 minutes they're not
coming with that [ __ ] scraper or they
scrape that
[ __ ] yeah if they don't [ __ ] come out
with a napkin like this and [ __ ] pour
the drink like this
yeah if i chew a [ __ ] baguette and i
go and the [ __ ] crumbs are all over
the place
i look at him and this this [ __ ]
doesn't come with a little scraper
you're supposed to be doing this every
single time
if they don't come over with that laser
razor blade and act like there's cocaine
on the table
i don't want it i'm not tipping you've
been to another restaurant since
that does that like do you go to those
often not during these times not during
the day so i'm not during these times
because they ain't open because they
ain't open no because since then because
like that
restaurant experience was like six years
ago like we paid 500
ahead of this [ __ ] restaurant was it
five hundred
yeah we went four back then we were poor
back then we were like four we're just
like
yeah and then this guy eats nine it
drinks ninety dollars worth of water no
no
i thought water was free ninety
no because they came with water right
and they beyond ten dollars so
they poured the water and i drank it on
my [ __ ] this is literally the best water
it was the water
it was but then we went to france we had
the same water and it was like three
dollars
we were so poor we wanted to feel like
we were really getting our money's worth
and then when we got the check it was oh
it was i thought it was like on tap but
it was
actual bottled water and i drank nine
bottles and each one was 10 bucks i'm
like what the [ __ ]
you know what oh [ __ ] how do you drink
food
[ __ ] good dude the restaurant that
came with the scraper though i was like
people do this dude i am surprised that
all of us didn't get together
and say dude i can't believe that this
food is like
so expensive it tastes like [ __ ] like
throw this [ __ ] back because i think all
of us were so broke
we thought we were wrong but then the
more we talked about it we're like
man that was bad food dude i think we
also had class too
so you want to cause ruckus nice i felt
good because
i was one of two people out of that
whole group that got the fish
that was that was fish we all got beef
and it was like the worst it's super
salty it was like
there's the kind of straights this big
yeah
what is a scraper by the way is it like
a bench scraper no so it's like a tape a
white tablecloth
table right like that that's like the
fancy [ __ ] setting like the full like
the whole
the whole nine yards yeah like five
forks and five spoons that's
those type of restaurants and then like
this like he comes out with the literal
like scraper thing what does it look
like is it metal
it looks like a butter knife or
something yeah kind of like a little
letter
opener kind of thing and then he comes
and he goes like this
and he just like scrapes it he like
collects it in a little like dustpan
looking thingy
very expensive crumbs you know what you
know i don't like which is like a new
norm
is when uh now especially with the
coronavirus in la and stuff like that
you buy something right so it's like you
don't touch anything it's all these like
plexiglass and it's just like tap card
readers or whatever right
but then with even with like square
readers they're always still turning
that [ __ ] around they're like you want
to tip
but for me also being like a waiter at a
restaurant like there's a there's a
difference between
serving somebody and being a cashier
yeah
in my personal opinion right i do i
believe in that too cash in a cashier
situation i'm like i don't
know how to justify tipping when it's
like every element of this transaction
is just
a normal point of sale yeah you go
through a drive-through of krispy kremes
and [ __ ]
like you want a tip i'm like what do you
mean i drove myself through this
[ __ ] yeah
but then because it's culverton's i'm
like all right so i think it's like you
don't
you don't go you don't go buy clothes
and oh you took the cash
at a table like somebody's preparing and
giving me something prepared ready to
eat or then cleaning up after me
that's not like a service that's not a
tip to me i agree but even before
covet times like when that happens to me
because they're standing right there
i feel weird if i just put no tip or
zero so i still tip
anyway even though they're stand like
they're doing nothing for me but i'm
like well if i'll get here
i've taken cashiers before though
because i'll be like
never been here what's good and then
they'll give me 20 different
recommendations
there is i'm like in a rush and i'm like
i'm in such a rush i don't be i don't
mean to be a dick but like i got to get
my drink and she goes
all right you'll be the first one i'm
like all right cool 20 here we go
and then that's different that's as a
service they are there
are serving you but i think in those
cases that's when
tipping at a cashier would be cool like
it's like that extra mile right sure
you know uh if those like fast casual or
whatever like jersey mics for example
like right there they do offer that that
option to tip the
the person who made your sandwich um and
then but they're always so friendly they
always strike up conversation too where
i'm like see that's like that's
a service even though they didn't help
me necessarily like decide or whatever
but they were still being pleasant
enough where i'm like
this made me feel good it depends on
because i'm watching that [ __ ]
the whole time so if he's making my
sandwich
and he's in between three or four
tomatoes to cover the sandwich
and i see him put three down and there's
like a half inch i'm like you could have
fit another tomato there
nope but if he's like hook you up and
the little tomatoes kind of sticking out
of the sandwich i'm like
[Laughter]
oh you gotta you gotta just say you're
hooking them up it's a mentality thing
right you just gotta be
that type of energy even if you're not
actually hooking them up
that's you gotta play that game and
that's that's what deserves a tip
that's what made us go with your
landscaper yeah yeah
that's what made us go with your
landscape why can't you feel like he's
hooking you up yeah yeah
he does he's good he's good that's what
you're working on okay
it's part of the game hello guys thank
you guys so much for watching all of our
videos and i know it's been a million
years
in the making but we finally got just
kidding news
merch yep so make sure you go down to
the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
you